Yeah, Twitch says I'm live. All right,
cool.
There's even some viewers.
Excellent. All right, let's get started.
Um, so today uh we get to today I'm very
excited about today. Today is vector
clocks day. Um so last time uh uh to
recap uh we talked about lamport clocks
uh and uh the quiz question last time uh
had to do with the the the relationship
between Lampport clocks and and
causality. Um so
in the context of this course uh
causality means the the the happens
before relation uh this thing. Um so the
relationship between between lamport
clocks and the happens before relation
uh is this uh if a happens before b then
that implies this double arrow here is
the implication arrow that the lamport
clock of a uh is less than the lamport
clock of b. Um so that that was what the
quiz question was last time. It was uh
um if you know that a a happens before b
then what if anything do you know about
the lamport clocks of a and b and this
is what you know um so so this is the
this is the relation relationship that
you have between the happens before
relation and lamport clocks um but but
what about the other direction if if the
lamport clock of a is less than the
lamport clock of b
uh then
is this True.
Oh, really? Interesting. You're not
seeing my um
You're not
Oh, no. Huh. Okay. Just a second.
Thanks for pointing that out.
Are you now seeing the right thing uh in
Zoom?
Great.
Sorry about the technical difficulties.
All right. So um
so now hopefully you see what I wrote
down a second ago uh which is we know
the relationship uh uh of lamport clocks
and uh and the happens before relation
says that uh if a happens before b then
you know that the lamport clock of a is
less than the lamport clock of b. Um but
this this implication in the other
direction uh do you know that
we do not. So we saw an example of that
last time. Uh so that's not true. So it
would really be nice to have some sort
of logical clock that did exactly
characterize the happens before
relation. Um happily such a thing exists
and it gets used all the time in
distributed systems. Uh and it's called
a vector clock.
So vector clocks were independently in
invented uh by two authors um Freriedman
Mattern
and Colin Fij.
and they each independently um wrote a
paper about this uh in 1988.
Uh so here's the property that's true of
vector clocks.
Uh
if a happens before b,
then the vector clock of a is less than
the vector clock of b.
And the implication goes in the other
direction too. So if the vector clock of
a is less than the vector clock of b
then you know a happens before b. Um so
in other words with vector clocks we
have both directions of this
implication. So it's if and only if uh
not just if like it was for lamport
clocks.
So this is huge uh because it means that
vector clocks like lamport clocks are
consistent with causality but unlike
lamport clocks they characterize
causality. So we say that vector clocks
are consistent with
and
characterize
causality.
Okay. So what are these vector clock
things? What is the definition of a
vector clock? Well, remember a lamport
clock uh is is just an integer, right,
that just gets assigned to an event. Um
so what do you suppose if that's what a
lamp clock is, what do you suppose a
vector clock is?
Magnitude and direction.
Okay, maybe you're thinking of vectors
in in terms of physics. Um, so if we
think of vectors uh in terms of of of
programming, a vector could have any
number of dimensions, right? Um, so
before we just had a single integer,
right? Um, so now we're going to have a
vector of integers or a list of
integers, some kind of sequence of
integers.
So
to dispense with any magic
A vector clock is just
sequence
of integers.
Here's how it works. So we say first of
all
every process
maintains a vector
of integers
initialized to zero.
Just like with lampport clocks, every
every process kept a counter, right? a
single number initialized to zero. Uh
for this every process is going to keep
a vector of integers initialized to
zero. How long of a vector? How many do
you think?
Yeah. Number of processes. That's right.
So if there were three processes then it
might look like this.
Okay. So before we wrote down rules for
uh for how these clocks get updated. Um,
so just like with lampport clocks, uh,
we're going to use vector clocks to
count events, but vector clocks are more
informative than lampport clocks.
So
if a lamp clock is, let's say, 17, then
that kind of just means 17 events have
occurred that I know about.
Um, but if I have processes Alice, Bob,
and Carol, and I have a vector clock um
that says
17 0 0,
each entry in here is going to
correspond to my one of my three
processes.
Um, so this vector clock of 1700 0 like
this, this describes a world in which
Alice has seen 17 events and Bob and
Carol haven't seen any. Uh, so this is a
more fine grained understanding of of
what has occurred than Lamport clocks,
right? A Lamport clock of 17 just says
17 events have occurred, but this says
something about who's seen what events.
Okay. So the next part of the definition
uh
on every event
a process
increments
its own
position.
in its
vector clock
and this includes internal events as
well as sends and receives. Somebody's
asking a really great great question in
chat which is well what if you don't
know how many processes there are in the
system? How would you how would you do
this? How would you handle this? Because
for example here uh I'm saying that the
the every process is going to maintain
this vector. So Alice, Bob, and Carol
are each going to keep a three element
vector because Alice, Bob, and Carol
each know about Alice, Bob, and Carol.
But what if the processes don't know
about the other processes that exist?
That's a great question. So vector
clocks only work if you have this fixed
ahead of time knowledge of how many
processes there are in the system.
Uh so that's a terrific question and
that's in fact uh one reason why uh
tracking causality with vector clocks
can be problematic and why some systems
choose not to do it or they might choose
to do it only with some subset of the
nodes. Uh but we'll see uh that this
this technique turns out to be uh pretty
generally useful despite its drawbacks.
Okay. So what's next? So we've seen
every process is going to keep a vector
and on every event a process is going to
increment its own position in the vector
clock. This is sounding not too
different from lampport clock so far
except that you you just increment your
own position instead of uh um the one
number that you have. Okay. What about
sending?
So we say
when sending a message
each process
includes
its current block
and this is after uh after incrementing
its own position because ascend is an
event. So we'll say
Okay, here's another question in chat.
Uh,
two processes can have a new event at
the same time, right? So, of course, in
the vector clock, you can only track the
events that you currently know about,
right? So, this uh this vector clock
here of 17, 0, and zero says that Alice
knows about 17 events. Uh Bob knows
about zero events and Carol knows about
zero events. Um if another event
happened right on Bob right now, uh say
it was a you know some event that uh
that was internal to Bob or even if Bob
just sent a message to Alice, Alice
doesn't know about that yet. So Alice's
clock can't increment at that point.
We'll see more examples of that soon.
Okay. And then the last thing that we
haven't talked about yet is is um is
receiving, right? So so what are the
rules for receiving? When we talked
about lamport clocks, we said that uh
your lamport clock increments to the
maximum of the clock that you receive on
a message plus your local clock plus
one.
Um so for this we say
when receiving a message
each process
updates its vector clock
to the max of
the received
vector clock and its own.
Um
and this is also
after incrementing
because a receive is an event also.
So those are the rules on one page.
But there's something that we haven't
really defined here. So before when we
were just talking about lamport clocks,
it was pretty easy to know what maximum
meant, right? We could we could pretty
easily take the maximum of two numbers.
Um but here I have this word maximum.
So what does this mean in the context of
vectors, right? If you have a vector of
integers, two vectors of integers, and
you want to take the maximum of of those
two vectors, how would you go about it?
Uh does anyone have a suggestion?
Yeah, take the max elementwise. Sure.
Um, so this is sometimes called the the
pointwise maximum also. Um,
so the notion of max max that we're
going to be using here is is pointwise
or elementwise maximum.
So if we have say two clocks and one of
them is say 1 12 4
and the other one is say 7 02
um what do we get uh when we take the
pointwise maximum of those.
Yeah, that's right. So, we should get
something like 7 12 4
Okay, good. All right. Now, how do we
know when one vector clock is less than
another?
So before I wrote this,
but I didn't give a definition for this
less than
comparator here. So we need to figure
out how we define that. Uh there's
another a question in chat. Somebody
asked to to see the definition of vector
clocks again. Okay. So, here's the here
are the rules for how to update vector
clocks.
I'll take a picture of it myself, too.
So it actually as far as this whether
whether you take the max first and then
increment um I'm actually not sure if
that makes a big difference. Um,
I wrote it that way in order to be
consistent with sending because of
course with sending it matters, right?
Because you want to make sure to
increment your clock before you send it
because you need the correct thing to be
sent there. Uh, but with this um, it
would be okay if you incremented your
own clock value, I think, before taking
the maximum.
So, that's not such a big deal.
All right. So now that that's been saved
and shared in chat, uh let's switch back
to this page.
Um okay, so what we were wondering about
was this less than thing here, right? Um
because this is true, right? I'm
claiming that this is true. Um but in
order for that to be meaningful, we have
to know what less than means when we're
comparing two vector clocks. Um so so
how do you know um when one vector clock
is less than another?
Um so it's it's slightly subtle. Um
we say that
uh the vector clock of A
is less than the vector clock of B when
um for all the positions in the vector
clock. So we're going to call them so so
let's say that these things uh these
vector clocks uh have elements um and
they're indexed by i. So we could say
at every index I, the vector clock of A
at that index has to be less than or
equal to the vector clock of B at that
index
for all
I. And
the vector clock of A is not equal to
the vector clock of B.
So this is uh this is a way to make this
strictly smaller comparison between
vector clocks. Um we say that the vector
clock of A is less than the vector clock
of B if for every for every index the
vector clock of I is less than or equal
to the vector clock of B. but also
they're not equal. So there has to be in
other words there has to be at least one
that's strictly smaller. Um so for
example we could look at an example of
this if we had let's say
um VC of A
that's like 2 0
um and VC of B
um
that's 3
to Z,
then that would be a case where we could
say that the vector clock of A um is
less than the vector clock of B. Um
because
the vector clock of A is less than or
equal to the vector clock of B less than
or equal to the vector clock of B in all
the positions and also they're not the
same.
So that's how we compare vector clocks.
Um how about another one? How about
this?
What if we had
VC of A being 220
and VC of B
of
1 2 3?
So
is the vector clock of A less than the
vector clock of B here.
This one is not. So
it's not the case that the vector clock
of A is less than the vector clock of B.
Um what about the other direction?
Is this true?
Is the vector clock of B less than the
vector clock of A?
No, that's not true either.
So in this case uh the events that would
get these two vector clocks attached to
them are considered concurrent
because we can neither say that the
vector clock of A is less than the
vector clock of B nor that the vector
clock of B is less than the vector clock
of A. So we would say that A and B are
are independent or concurrent.
Questions about this so far?
uh
so there was a question about the
definition here. So
yeah, so
we say that the vector clock of A is
less than the vector clock of B if
for every index
the number at that index is less than or
equal to of A is less than or equal to
the other one. So notice that this is a
less than or equal to comparator here,
not uh not strictly less than. Um so
it's less than or equal to. So it's okay
if they're the same. uh in almost all of
the positions, right? In this example
here, they are the same in all but one
position, right? Um but there is one
position where this one is bigger and
that's captured by this this last
condition here where we say that that
the vector clocks can't be equal.
So
let's go through an example and let's
talk about assigning vector clocks to
events.
So, back to our friends Alice, Bob, and
Carol.
All right, let's see. I'm going to put a
whole bunch of events up here.
That should do it. Okay, so let's try to
follow those rules that we had before
and try assigning vector clocks to all
these events. So we're going to start
out uh with every process having
its vector clock initialized to zero.
And um I probably won't update that
these up here as I go along. um instead
I'll just write the vector clocks of
each event uh next to the events uh and
we'll try to uh keep track of uh of what
the local clocks would be updated to as
we go along. Okay, so
starting with Carol. Um so here's an
event here. Um it's the first event uh
that Carol knows about and Carol doesn't
for herself and Carol doesn't know about
any of Alice and Bob's events. Um, so
the vector clock here is going to be
001.
Um, because we're going to assume that
those are that's the sequence of
positions in this vector 01. That's
another thing that has to be the case
with vector clocks. All of the processes
have to agree on an order uh for the
processes in the vector clock. Um, so
this is something else that would have
to be known ahead of time in order for
this approach to work. Uh and you could
have some ordering that made sense,
right? Uh um you could uh you could use
like lexographical order of the IP
addresses or something like that. Um but
this would be this would be something
that the machines would have to agree on
otherwise your your vector clocks would
be nonsensical.
All right. So this is uh this is the
clock for this event right here. And
just like with uh uh with lampport
clocks, vector clocks get sent along uh
with messages. So this this clock of 001
is going to get attached to this message
as it gets as it gets sent to Bob. Bob
is going to receive it and he's going to
compare it with his local clock value uh
which is just 0000. Um so well 001 is
bigger than 0000 according to the the
notion of bigger that we defined. Um so
the bigger one will win. Um and then Bob
of course also has to increment his own
clock position. So this will become
zero
one one right here because Bob's
position in the vector is is this uh
this middle position.
Okay. So then Bob has to send a message
here. Uh what should be the vector clock
for this message send right here? This
this second event on Bob. Can somebody
tell me?
That's right. It should be 021.
Message gets sent with the 021 on it. It
arrives over here at Alice. Alice's
local clock is still 000.
Um, but Alice is going to increment her
own position in the clock when she
receives it. So it's now going to be 1 2
1.
Now here's a send from Alice. So the
clock here should be 221 because Alex is
going Alice is going to increment her
own position.
The message gets sent over here to Bob.
Oops. Let's deal with this previous
message from Bob first. Um so Bob sends
a message here. Um what should the
vector clock on this uh this message
should be? It's the third event on Bob's
process.
That's right. This one should be 031.
The message gets sent. Now, Carol's
current vector clock is 001. And that
gets compared with this 031 over here.
Those get compared. We take the
pointwise maximum. This one wins
and then Carol's local clock gets
updated. So this becomes 032 over here.
Now let's deal with this one here. Uh so
here's a case where we have a clock
that's coming in from Alice, right?
We're looking at the fourth event on
Bob. Now, we have a clock that's coming
in from Alice that said 221. And then we
have Bob's current clock that said 031.
Um, so how are those going to get
combined?
Yeah, we're going to take the maximum of
them of each position, right? Um, so the
maximum of two and zero, right, is going
to be two.
Um the maximum of three and two is going
to be three. Uh and we're also going to
increment it, right? Because it's Bob's
position. Um so that's going to become
four. And then of course the maximum of
one and one is just one. So the vector
clock of that event right there becomes
2 41.
Um
let's just keep filling these out here.
So this one down here is send from Bob.
Um Bob increments his own position
there. So that one will be 251.
Here's a send from Carol. Um because
it's Carol sending the message, she's
going to increment her own position. So
it's 033.
That gets sent over here to Alice.
What does Alice do? She takes the 033
and takes the pointwise maximum of it
with her own clock, which was 221. Um
and she increments her own position as
well. So the max of two and zero is two
plus her own plus it's her own position.
So the first thing becomes three. The
max of two and three is three. The max
of 1 and three is three. So that clock
is 333.
This one over here
251 gets sent from Bob to Carol. Carol's
current clock is 033.
How do those get combined? Zero and two.
The maximum of those is two.
Three and five, the maximum of those is
five. Three and one, the maximum of
those is three. And then it gets
incremented because it's Carol's
position.
And then finally, this is Carol's last
send. So this one will be 255.
That one will get sent over here.
Somebody want to tell me what the last
uh vector clock will be for this receive
from Alice.
Yeah, that one should be 455. That's
right.
Uh, so there was a question about this
241 up here. Um, so this one, uh, so
Bob's current clock right here is 031,
right? And then Alice's Al Alice has
221. So the way that those get combined
is uh you take the pointwise max of each
element. So the max of two and zero is
two and the max of two and three is
three. Um but Bob um is incrementing
when you when you receive you that's an
event on you. So you also you increment
that. Um so there there's a question do
you add and then increment or is it okay
to increment and then add? I think it's
actually I think it actually works to
increment and then add. But the way that
I wrote it down in the definition before
uh um was
um when you receive a message, you
update your vector clock to the max of
the received vector clock and your own
uh and that you do that after
incrementing. Um but I I think it would
actually work to do it either way.
Okay, so here's our full picture again.
Um, by the way, this is from uh
Wikipedia from the uh article about
vector clocks if you want to go u uh
compare it uh to what they showed. Uh
they have a slightly different way of
drawing the picture, but it's it's the
same information. Um so, okay. So, let's
let's look at this event right here. Um
this one that we dwelled on for a
minute. Let's call it event A.
It has vector clock 241.
So now we can ask what are the events
that are in the causal history of this
event A? Well, so based on what we know
about the happens before relation um we
know we know some things, right? We know
that everything that came before it on
its process line is going to be in its
causal history. Uh so let's look at
those events and look at the vector
clocks of those events. Well, what are
those clocks? Well, there's this one had
011 and this one had 021.
This one had 031.
Uh, so if we look at those clocks,
right? Um, they're all less than this
241, right? Well, and what else is in
its causal history? Well, there's these
two events on Alice, right? um there in
its causal history. If we follow the uh
if we use our rule of thumb, right, that
uh causality is graph reachability,
right? Then we can see that these two
events are are in the causal history of
A. And if we look at those clocks, um
they're also less than the clock on A.
And then there's this event back here on
Carol uh with clock 001. So that one is
also in the causal history of A. if you
follow the path uh through the um the
the lamport diagram here. So we have a
bunch of events here and I'll just
circle the vector clocks of all the
events that I can see that are in the
causal history of of A.
So we can see that all those events are
in A's causal history because we could
reach A from them using that principle
that causality is graph reachability in
spacetime that we talked about
previously.
Um but what you notice about all these
vector clocks of all these events that
are in A's causal history is that
they're all smaller than A.
And likewise, if we looked at an event
that was causally later than A, we would
see that its vector clock had to be
bigger. So this event here, for example,
is causally later than A, and its vector
clock is bigger. And this one here is
causally later than A, and its clock is
bigger as well.
Well, what about those events that have
a vector clock that's neither smaller
nor bigger than A? So, for example,
right here on Carol, um there's an
event, let's call it B.
Um, so this event has a vector clock of
032.
How does that one compare with the
vector clock of A?
Is it bigger? Is it smaller?
Right. It's neither bigger nor smaller.
So we say that these two events here
are independent
or we say they're causally unrelated or
we say that they're concurrent.
Those things are all synonyms.
So this is great, right? Because now
instead of having to think about graphs
and reachability and all that, now if we
want to know if one event
potentially caused another event, all
that we have to do is just compare a
bunch of numbers in a vector. Guess what
computers are really, really good at?
Computers are really good at comparing a
bunch of numbers in vectors.
So
this is great, right? We've taken this
really complicated notion of causality
and we've boiled it down to just
comparing numbers and vectors and with
that we can exactly capture the happens
before relation that we've been talking
about. Computers are good at graphs too
but usually when they are good at graphs
it's because the the graphs have been
boiled down to some sort of
representation that amounts to vectors
of numbers I think. So vector clocks are
great um and they're really widely used
uh and we're going to see this concept
of vector clocks coming back uh multiple
times in this course. Uh questions about
any of this
Yeah, somebody asked. Okay, so so why
why are A and B independent? Well, if
you look at their clock values, so A has
a clock value of 241, right? And B has a
clock value of 032. If I looked at those
two clock values
and I and you asked me which one is
bigger, right?
Well, if I tried to argue that this A
was bigger, right, the 241 was bigger,
then you could say, well, no, because
this B is bigger in this last position
here, right? And if you tried to argue
that B was bigger, um, then I'd say no
because A is bigger in this the first
two positions. So there's so neither of
them is definitely bigger, right? So
we know that it's not the case that that
one is less than the other. And so
that's how we know that
um that these two events are
independent. Whereas if you look at some
event that causally precedes A, which
would be any of these other circled ones
up here, um maybe I shouldn't have
circled this one because that that makes
it look as though it's part of this
whole set. Um so think of this circle as
being sort of a special circle here.
Um but any of these other circled ones
back here that are that are uh in the
figure um these all have vector clocks
that are that are less than the vector
clock of event A according to the
definition that we're talking about.
That's right. Yeah. So there's lots of
other events that are going to be
concurrent with a as well. Yeah. Uh so
this this here
We'll give it the same special kind of
circle
is also concurrent with a. Sure.
So, some folks are asking some questions
in chat that I'm that I'm not sure I
understand. Um but uh hopefully I can
try to clear some of them up later. Um
so one question is uh if there's this
031 I think some folks were wondering
about ex how exactly this 241 gets
calculated here. Um, so this I think the
key to remember is this this 221 gets
sent along here
as part of the metadata on this message
from Alice to Bob.
And so this 221 gets sent along here.
And so when Bob receives this message,
Bob sees that vector clock that came
along on the message and compares it
with his own local clock. And so that's
where we get the two, right? Because two
is the the pointwise max of zero and
two. Uh the middle value, we take the
pointwise max of two and three, uh which
is three, but then we increment it
because Bob is counting this event that
happens on himself as an event. And so
that then we get four and then the max
of one and one is just one. So that's
how we calculate the two four what
other questions?
Here's the definition one more time
of how you compute vector clocks.
So, here's a quiz question
and I'll share
It's a little bit hard to read, isn't
it? I don't know why.
There we go.
Here
is the quiz link
on Slack.
Give people a little while to fill that
out.
Make it a little bigger so it's readable
on Twitch.
should be a relatively easy one, I
think.
All right.
So, as the last few of the responses
come in, um we can start to talk about
something new. So, back uh in a previous
lecture, I I briefly mentioned this word
protocol.
Um so, what did we say a protocol is?
So we'll say a protocol is a set of
rules
that computers use to communicate with
each other.
It's not exactly a formal definition,
but it'll do. Okay. So in particular,
it's a set of rules that can tell you
what messages you're allowed to send
in terms of what messages you've
received.
Okay? So say say let's think of a really
simple protocol. So let's say you have a
protocol where one machine can wake up
and send the message, hi, how are you?
And the machine that receives that
message can respond with good, thanks.
or we'll say the machine must respond
with good thanks if it if it gets that
message. Um, so here's a here's a
lamport diagram that describes a run of
that protocol between Alice and Bob.
So Alice says, "Hi, how are you?
Alice is maybe in a much more
magnanimous mood than before when she
said that Bob smells.
Okay. So, there's a protocol.
All right. or it's a particular run of a
protocol.
How about a different run of this
protocol?
Well, Bob could be the one to ask,
right? It could be this.
So that could be another run of the same
protocol.
All right. So nothing in our description
of the protocol said that Alice had to
be the first to talk, right? So these
are both valid runs of the protocol,
right?
Okay. So what about something like this?
So that one is clearly a protocol
violation, right? Not only is it
violating the social protocol, but it's
also violating this this particular
protocol that we just wrote down. Okay,
so that's not allowed.
Okay,
what about this?
So, is the protocol being violated here?
What do you think?
Not yet. Yeah, that's a good answer.
Yeah, this is kind of a weird case,
right? Because these lines go on
indefinitely.
So, it's not necessarily a protocol
violation, right? Because the protocol
could still be running, right? We might
have just interrupted the protocol in
the middle.
In fact, maybe what this diagram
actually looks like is more like
this. Maybe it's like
So maybe Alice is a little bit slow on
the uptake, right? Uh but if we cut off
our diagram right here, right? We don't
know.
So in terms of lampport diagrams,
there's not any difference between this
what I have shown on this sheet here and
what I have up here, right? Maybe Alice
is working from home. Sure. Um, so
there's no difference in terms of in
terms of lampport diagrams uh between
this picture where Alice responds fairly
promptly and this one where Alice might
be a little slow. distance doesn't mean
anything in these pictures for that
matter. There is no difference between
either of those and one that looked like
this where Alice did respond promptly,
but the message just took a really long
time to arrive on Bob's end.
So what that means is that when I talk
about a particular run of a protocol
and I draw one of these things, um you
should understand that they they could
mean different things in terms of of
physical clocks, but they mean the same
thing in terms of logical clocks that is
with regard to ordering of messages. Um,
but even though we know that the the
diagram where
Alice is quickly responds to the good
thanks and one where she takes longer to
respond,
um, even though we know that those are
the same in terms of perhaps in terms of
lamport diagrams,
there's still infinitely many lamport
diagrams that describe correct runs of
this protocol. Um, for instance, you
could have uh any number of back and
forth exchanges, right? Uh, how are you?
Good, thanks. How are you? Good, thanks.
Adnauseium, right?
So if I asked you to draw a landport
diagram that was some sort of complete
characterization
of this how are you good thanks protocol
then you wouldn't be able to do it
because there are infinitely many
correct ways for a run of this protocol
to go. Uh so I usually won't ask you to
do that. But I usually won't ask you to
draw a lamport diagram that describes a
protocol because it's not possible to do
it right because there are a whole lot
of different because a lamp diagram
describes a particular run right and
there are multiple correct runs often
infinitely many correct runs of a
protocol. Um so so that's not something
that you can do. What you can often do
though is draw a lamport diagram that
characterizes a violation of a protocol.
Uh and we did do that a second ago. So
we put a vi a particular violation
of this protocol uh was this one right
here
where Alice just says good thanks uh
without being asked a question. Um so
that's what we'll do quite often, right?
Oh, so here's a question. Yeah, somebody
asks, "What if they both send hi, how
are you at the same time, right?
And maybe these messages cross over,
right?
So that would not be a violation of the
protocol, would it? There's nothing in
there that violates the protocol."
Um, so this is the only one that I've
shown so far. this one where Alice just
says good thanks completely unprompted.
Uh that's the only violation that I've
that I've shown so far.
So the reason I'm talking about this uh
is because we're going to in this course
we're often going to talk about uh
violations of some sort of property,
some sort of correctness property as
being embodied by a diagram.
And so an anomaly is a run that violates
the the property that we want to have be
true. And so a diagram uh can usually
characterize that anomaly in some sort
of meaningful way.
Uh so in particular, we're going to
start to talk about some properties,
some correctness properties that we want
to have be true. Uh, and
one way to kind of summarize those
properties and kind of be able to talk
about them is to draw a picture of a
violation of a property. Uh, so let's
see an example of that really quickly.
Um, so here's a particular correctness
property.
Actually,
you know what? I'm going to call it FIFO
delivery.
FIFO delivery.
If a process
sends
message M2
after message M1,
any process
delivering both
delivers M1 first.
So this will be confusing unless I
explain what deliver means. Uh we talked
about sending and receiving. Uh and
those are pretty intuitive, right? So
sending is something you do. Sending a
message is something you do. Receiving a
message is something that happens to
you, right? You don't control when
messages arrive at you. They just do or
they don't. Um, but delivering is
actually something that you do with a
message that you receive. So, a protocol
can wait to deliver a received message
until the right time. Uh, so if you want
to, you can receive messages and then
cue them up until it's time to read
them. Um, this is actually a very
important mechanism uh, which we'll talk
about more later. Um, but a violation of
FIFO delivery would look like this.
Or if you don't like the idea of of uh
arrows going backwards in time, then you
could draw it more like this.
So this is an example of a FIFO anomaly.
FIFO delivery says that this particular
anomaly won't happen.
Uh so we'll talk a lot more about this
next time because we're almost out of
time and we're also going to look at
some other examples of uh of delivery
guarantees that you might want to try to
ensure. Uh but um this concept of
delivery as opposed to receiving is very
important. Uh so just to recap um
receiving
uh you don't control
delivery.
You do
All right, it's 10:25. So that's it for
today. I will see you next time.